welcome to this video this is coverage
for round seven of the sink filled cap
currently harden sent Lewis USA yeah
let's look at this rounds games again a
very interesting round and of course it
is a really great tournament and I mean
okay everyone is talking about the
fantastic run that car wanna is doing
but also in then general that's a lot of
lots of fighting games and and very fun
to look at so really enjoyable to watch
this tournament let's see what happened
in this rod topple off aronia you have
two of the tail enders they both really
have a rotten tournament let's see what
they did in a game so Queens gambit
their own young place with night bd7
interesting choice he sometimes plays
this line um topple off now comes up
with an interesting concept to place g3
that's not a very common move but an
interesting move to get them or more
fighting position the positions coming
from the classical Queens gambit like
like Bishop g5 or sometimes Bishop f4
has also played or the capture these are
sometimes a little bit term yeah a
little bit stale because they have been
played so often and g3 is a little bit
of a fresh approach it done sort of
place in the Catalan but there's
somewhat unusual placements of those two
nights so it's a little bit of a
different flavor within the Catalan and
it's not so much theoretically explored
so interesting way to play aronia took
Bishop g2 would be eight yeah would be a
Tercel really very straightforward like
wants to play b5 and keep the pawn as
simple as that and this gets you have
the more annoying with this night
already on c3 very often be five
it's questionable in the Catalan to keep
the pawn but when the night is already
on c3 it gets a little bit more
interesting for black SEO very often
have this be 5 b-4 with the tempo um and
the night cancer comes under attack yeah
white probably does not want to allow be
five so he plays a form making sure that
the media p5 is not possible yeah here
there are of course other possibilities
but Iranian played Bishop before an
interesting choice see that he already
spent a couple of minutes this is
certainly not a position that has been
part of both players preparation mud
sure maybe am Topalov had had this idea
briefly explored before but this is
nothing that you would analyze to move
20 or something so basically playing a
game now yeah bishop to before is a good
move to occupy the week before square he
does not even try to keep the pawn which
would be probably yeah ill-advised
anyway castles castles yeah and now the
problem is how does white get the porn
back there is no clear route to that the
knight on c3 is for example just
blocking this natural route for the
Queen to regain the pawn why displaying
92 this is a safe way to get the porn
back yeah Knight b6 does not make much
sense he is white is able to play at
five so he cannot keep it but 92
relinquishes control over a five so if
I've as possible and very often in
Queens gambit type of structures if
black manages to play e5 and get his
Bishop liberated the problems are really
over for black and I think this is
probably the case here black does not
have any particular problems it looks
them quite active at first for wide but
this move is a very good way to continue
black is using this week Square on b3
and at same time attacking the Queen
yonder for so white has to react and he
really does not have any big choice than
exchanging Queens it's also it's not a
problem with white but i don't mean
black ass probably equalized here rook
takes you should a form attacking c7 so
black plays 96 all very logical and the
bishop dropped back to e3 yeah in this
situation here and as we see both
players already have spent substantial
time they were really playing here not
repre ducing some prep and heap like
maybe could have gone from 94 this would
have been an interesting choice yeah
just centralizing the night and sort of
tempt white to take it on yeah maybe he
would have taken it not clear to me
maybe 94 was rejected due to ideas like
this I'm not entirely sure this is a
pawn sacrifice Channing this black black
is very much behind in development this
can easily scare you something like this
for example wider threatening made and
threatens the the night so the only move
especially 6 and yeah this is for me not
clear even this type of position is not
totally clear as white has some pressure
here on the pawns on maybe Aronian
rejected the 94 idea due to line like
that where he is very much behind in
development otherwise this looks like a
fine move 94 the capture is certainly
not varying black too much we see
something similar in the game he played
a 60 just removing the pawn from it and
only seven from the attack 95 played
this am a little bit of a repetition and
now I think to polyp should definitely
put something on the default Brooke fd1
probably taking control over the default
square however he played a book FC one
and here um yeah aronian took the chance
to play 94 this is a somewhat better
version
offer the thing from before I say even a
six is inserted I'm Jan what should why
do know the pile of decided to take it
but after that it's pretty clear that
black is taking over the cause of the
game however by now it's a bit tricky
this is a this is a threat so Luke see
one was probably just not precise if you
need to take now the whole thing is
certainly good for black yeah we see
this be 36 black is just enjoying the
bishop pair and this Bishop is sitting
lightly on the dark squares wow this is
not really doing much however it gets
very mysterious now there should be six
and now I mean 83 is also may be
questionable here to pile of plate III
and here it's really really amazing that
aronia now played look to d8 he just
went back while he could have played
rock d3 and it's it's really mysterious
why he didn't do that it's just
attacking in the c3 night which needs to
move so probably night a 22 attack there
before Bishop and then you just take me
three and I porn up for really not much
it's a really mysterious moment I really
don't know what what Aronian was was
afraid of its it looks very
straightforward why the comp also gives
just black it's black just a pawn plus
so I really took no it's mysterious of
course they're both not in great shape
at this tournament it also read said
aronian has some health problems maybe I
I read that he had some some sort of
some sort of medical thing done to him I
don't know some operation I don't know
what it was exactly nothing nothing very
threatening or anything but something
that very much will distract you um okay
well anyway this was a strange spot as
black wood with roop d3 probably gotten
a very big advantage he just retreated
and now the worst is over white
his night to d4 and black still enjoys a
good position because he controls most
of the queenside the the be four square
and so on it's easier for black to play
but it's nothing as threatening as
before we had an interesting moment
later here here rolling out how the very
nice move look to be five funny move
after the capture here black guy just
has a good position due to the to the
fork here very nice so wider could take
and now we could go to be form then item
here this structure is basically kept
until the end of the game they shuffled
a bit here here they went for a
repetition to draw in fact the final
position it is absolutely not necessary
for black to to exact accept this draw
and this repetition um black is still
better here he has chances to grindr
white further with the queenside being
being under pressure I guess that maybe
the the tournament situation that is
simply not good for aronia and yeah
maybe if he's really not 100% top shape
from a physical point of view I'm then
maybe he's in his decision is influenced
by that um I think this is for an
example of position if you give this to
to Carlson and there is nothing special
going on and like in a draw is good
enough to secure the word championship
or whatever that he would definitely
play this until tomorrow morning and try
to grind out a win but it's not like
black wins or something but he could
definitely have tried on okay they
played a draw both suffering in this
event the next game to look at is
Townsend Nakamura yeah modern classic in
oh hey and the weird thing is that in a
combo I never managed to win a game
against car
even though we had some great positions
so it's 11 0 table of cards and before
the game yeah we have a sloth defense in
Carden plate 93 yeah here nakamura
captured on c4 that's an interesting
interesting sideline yeah I still think
it should be called a sideline it's not
a very very common line to play but
interesting for black and one reason why
black is going for this after all is
let's say you want to play the classical
slab this slab accepted in a way where
you take um and you here don't like to
face the movie 3 where why it is so
keeping the pawn then you need to make a
choice you can take here on move 3 which
is Nakamura's choice to get more
accepted classical Slav feeling in the
position all you need to play here
something entirely different like e6 or
g 6 a-6 whatever but a totally different
position saudi take c is very often an
interesting choice for players who want
to play the classical slap but don't
want to study those sidelines the point
is that after a move like this eva is
also possible black is temporarily
keeping the pawn really possible and now
after a fun and be for night efore and
that's also night h who and so on but
this is the main line you place this
this funny movie yeah it's a very
strange-looking line line if you have
never seen it before back to d2 yeah
white is moving again the night but he
wants to get the pawn like back yeah
black pushes and now wyd returns to be
one very funny position but the the
simple effect is if white gets the porn
back he is at the pawn down a moment at
the moment if he gets it back without
any any serious thing happening then he
will be better due to the pawn structure
and to the probability
and that you will be taking when he
takes on c3 with the night so for
example if black plays a move like that
yeah i'm going to take Queen somewhere
then or maybe here Bishop t2 and here
white will be better the c6 part is just
a weakness and wider will gain even more
time with possible moves of the night ok
black could maybe just retreat but how
attractive is that yeah or just bishop d
to Luke see one the see ponyo is just we
gon c 6 so it's all about a concrete
justification of blacks play yeah Quincy
to again wants to get get it back yeah
here in this position the most common
moves is night a 6 which has a decent
results for black but it wasn't played
my Nakamura he played a hive and we
planed after relatively a quick thought
so this is a different idea and and
certainly interesting council replied
9003 entire Nakamura sank into into deep
thought um which is interesting because
this is very near what is theoretically
well explored so it's not that we are
talking about the totally a new position
or a great new concept what he probably
should do here is to take on d form
which is probably not super attractive
but the consequence of e5 something like
this probably and and then play this
position however this looks better for
white I mean there's no doubt that that
widest is slightly slightly better here
but it seems that he needs to do
something like that what he played after
lie about 20 minutes is 9 a-6 and to be
honest um maybe he confused them those
lines I really don't know that the big
problem is after night asics problem is
the wrong word I mean Black is just
losing here almost here calzon now took
five with the night and the problem is
that what it looks like Black has some
tactical chances here based on this
diagonal there simply is nothing maybe a
la camara made some some tactical
misjudgment here problem is you play
night before what else is there I mean
why does going for this or queen bee
three to attack f7 you will need to be
quit he went night before queen bee
three and now we have the main thread on
f7 it's almost major take on f7 take on
f8 winning so black really has to react
to that what should he do he played p
should be six we will look at this and
soon but there is no other move really
what what's what's the alternative
something like let's say queen d 5 now
cuida five Bishop c4 this is not maybe
one hundred percent cap white can also
just take or take on c three years it's
both very good this is not helping night
h 6 i'm okay i just take this and why
did the pawn up here he's basically
having a great position and and an extra
pawn so this is cannot be it so Bishop
e6 was played and now Bishop c4 I mean
this is just waiting for work there is
really no no way around it he went as c2
I can read it if he takes white can also
take with the night little little detail
attacking the Queen yeah something like
this yeah it's not helping I mean check
the wider King in the middle is no
problem it's probably black skin with
less safe I went c2 and now Carlton just
took only six I I started to watch the
game around here and I thought that also
d2 or Knight c3 was fine and it seems to
be this was was my choice being a wimp
as usual trying to keep it safe but even
this seems to just win something like
that for example you you can easily
afford stuff like that there is no no
attack yeah but this was played by cards
I allowed this double check but it's
really no big deal as why it has all the
threats here on the king black can
muster play something like this takes
and he took only six yeah if he takes
here key then this is all so
overwhelming hanks squid be seven or all
kinds of a text rook t1 it'sit's check
just not a pretty sight and here a
little point the night is threatening
this decisive entry into blacks position
which means that black really does not
have a big choice he needs to play with
Queen d5 to trade queens otherwise he
even would get mated but okay takes and
now 94 yeah this is something that with
technical player like cards and of
course is will wind relatively easily
the only thing that white needs to do is
to be careful to pick up the sea to pawn
at the right moment if we do a county em
why this had six pounds blacks got five
points and the seat upon which will be
lost so it's essentially two pawns white
only needs to be as mentioned careful
that he picks it up under the right
circumstances rookie two rooks e1 makes
lots of sense takes takes night before
yeah covering it for the moment but we
only need to reposition the night or
exchange the night on before to get them
to get the pawn so he's maneuvering this
night 31
and now I for little detail but
important if you take here black will
play 93 and take on your hive it's still
excellent provide but there is no reason
to give up this this pawn chain this
advanced porn is some is valuable you
can just pick up c21 later and not give
it up at all yeah we have karana fk1 now
can we are continuing that x f4 is a
little little trick but it is not really
varying wide too much check this after
this yeah one of those pawns will get
lost and this is the porn here on on the
C file yeah rook endgame where black is
some two points down he's got the a porn
but this is at the moment securely
blockaded and hive against two is too
much white basically just needs to push
the pawns and this is easy work for your
champion yeah here group d 7 f 7 is the
mating idea check which forced nakamura
to go back check and here this is just
check the easiest transposing check to
the king at porn endgame wear white is
well within the square of the pawn and
play it on for a moment Bhatia Nakamura
reside I think it's it's a good thing
even for those top players to continue
some moves to really show why it is it
is lost here it gets very apparent to to
almost all spectators where black is
resigning this point is going away and
black can never take on e4 as an f6 is
promoting the pawn to a new queen so
white will just pick up the pawn and
then return with the King all the way
here to support his pawns yeah nice win
for cards in very effortless game if you
look at
the clock times they start with 90
minutes here and and an increment so if
we M if we look at this forget the clock
times a thousand is playing just quickly
yeah it is just spending one or two
minutes for each movement it is
relatively simple yeah okay so only
spending about half an hour check out
the first 40 moves and then he gets 30m
miranti gets three additional minutes
and he basically spent like an hour or
something on the game and it wasn't very
difficult um a bit mysterious this night
a six in this moment where night xe5
Bishop c4 is almost winning for white
it's really everything else would be an
understatement yeah so calzon with
another win against nakamura really
cannot handle handle guards I really
don't know what this is I mean it
sometimes happens but this is one of the
worst scores that that is known i think
in top-level chess there have been some
some comparable things in the in the
past for example latvian or longtime
spanish grand ma selects a sheer off he
played Kasparov and in tons of games
really and he never managed to win one
game he lost Tony would never want the
singer game and I think that maybe the
the difference in playing strength of
bros players with sheer oven in his
prime was probably comparable still he
he should have won one or two games
maybe against Kasparov but he never
managed so when he accountant with the
plus one squad he said out of the the
biggest slump plus one does not sound
brilliant for the world champion but
this is still a 2840 performance so
nothing sorry nothing a terrible and he
will have of course next round the game
against Cara wanna to if he wins it to
sort of get some
revenge for the head for the first turn
okay now look at now we look at the most
interesting game maybe of the round how
does carwin I do hit this time he has
got six out of six and now plays black
against the maxima Sheila graph who is
not in a in a great shape in this
tournament that that's it's pretty clear
but still with white not not an easy
opponent let's see we have the Queens
gambit declined with Bishop e7 that's a
somewhat surprising choice and carolina
i think if i read this correctly later
said that he didn't expect one before
but 93 type of opening um yeah
interesting karana is a very flexible
player he plays a normally rather
dynamic openings like the green felt
something a bit more aggressive but he
can also play those kind of solid lives
as we have here Bishop e7 is a little
move on a wrinkle Knight f6 being the
traditional move however after this
let's always the exchange variation
which continues to score and very nicely
for wide and lots of black players I'm
do want to avoid this this type of
exchange and play Bishop e7 um I myself
play this line quite often as black
especially if I am don't term ya don't
mind to have the somewhat dull position
if I mean sometimes you just want to
have a simple to play game and I like to
play the Queens gambit declined them in
in this case if I have a good opponent
and I'm fine with a solid position yeah
but should be seven and now why plays
Bishop f4 interesting the normal movie
is not a 39 f six and then white has
this typical choice Bishop here or
Bishop to f4 and this Bishop f4 is a
very well-known line in the game we get
something very comparable Bishop f 19 f
63 castles now look see
one at 97 yeah so white has substituted
the move Knight f3 with Roxy one very
interesting what is the point there are
some points behind that on especially
concerning what black exactly is playing
now after a move like c5 this is what
what the Rashida graph played and there
is a very comparable a position in the
other line but there the night is still
on them is on a 3 and the rookies on a 1
and in this position the other position
there is night h5 because this diagonal
is blocked which is not possible here so
black is lacking this idea of playing
night to h5 which would exchange this
bishop on f4 little little move order
idea here by a by white um yeah kawana
just played 94 here this is a new idea
in fact the hoop position is not very
well known but 94 is a new idea it was
also possible to just place his six and
continue with b6 and a 5 as it is done
in the other line but black has yeah for
faded for faded the option of plain i th
590 forever is interesting just jumping
right into the middle of the board if
white now takes D takes this is a not
very threatening for black there are
even ideas to play a quickie 5 for
example if what now goes this then
besides ideas like yeah like normal
ideas like c6 be six or night f65
there's also a move like this which
might lead to interesting play like this
is clearly good for black oh sorry this
was a bit much
so probably this capture and after this
this is an interesting position the
Pawnee only five is not particularly
strong and this could be a exploit from
the black side you are like taking on d1
check Andrew p8 not clear at all this
point is not easily defended yeah there
are some interesting ideas but Maxime
just played Bishop d3 yeah f5 plate
going into a stone wall type of position
fortifying the night there was also this
funny possibility taking rook takes nd5
this was pointed out by the engine to me
and it has a very funny idea if white
now takes like this there is the
strange-looking move b6 and this is
quite quite interesting as you can see
if white takes there's Bishop before and
we suddenly win the exchange very weird
motif and if white plays before we play
a five and this is somehow crumbling for
white the big dark squares and the
strange position of the rook is fatal so
Phaedra which is why it's not losing but
this is definitely an interesting
position for black so this would have
been interesting but it's a very
computer ish line admittedly f5 is okay
of course 93 c 6 yeah at this moment I'm
there also was the idea to play g5 which
looks bit crazy but it needs to be
examined after Bishop g3 f form a very
greedy option after the game marijuana
said that he remembered that this idea I
was existing here maybe he had to look
at this line at some point um and he
thought that it was very risky which is
probably true white can do something
like that he has no way to save the
bishop but if we look at this position
maybe this can be improved upon but
definitely why it has a dangerous attack
black is lacking two pawns and he has
this kind of yeah very open King side
structure yeah look f7 maybe and then we
we have a ton of ideas as wide I can can
play can play here drop the bishop back
Queen D free looks very risky to claim
he just went we'll see six playing solid
stuff yeah white played 95 this is a
really normal move occupying this week
md5 square the whole structure does not
seem to be very problematic to me for
black as it can relatively quickly
exchanged the pieces that can occupy e5
quickly like here we should f6 got the
stratum and here on em the our plate 92
yeah probably a good typical idea um
white cannot play something like f1 s
cree nation it's there for that very
hard to prevent the movie 5 and if Black
gets to play your five in this structure
he certainly is okay um why Tia had had
an interesting idea this was prepared by
ninety to arrive of course very logical
and now Russia allograft played the
Queen a form and this ultimately turns
out to be a mistake um yeah it was funny
Kasparov posted a tweet way questioned
the move and he said I would like to ask
her the white player what the idea
behind the move was he would have
thought that why should simply take on
e5 so probably something like this just
take him and put the knight on d4 with
about equal maybe um yeah he asked why
this was played and it was funny that
Maxine rush telegrapher later on certain
answer to the tweet these are the
beauties of some social media nowadays
that you can I really have this kind of
dialogue going on um yeah queen fo he
said that his idea was to to play the
capture on if I
so let's say black place place a nothing
yeah I like this it does not help much
but this is what he wanted to do you
wanted to place the Queen there and then
play the move every this this kind of
idea was in his mind so this makes Queen
a for a little bit more understandable
however he had a misjudged at least one
reply come on anam played queen age for
a very a simple idea why not just make
the guy that almost made thirsty one
left but attacking f2 instead he also
had 26 which would have been a very
interesting and maybe even stronger one
point is that after castles is the move
f4 which goes straight for the throat
and also entails a an additional
tactical idea after this for example
Black has oops i take c 5 funny idea
also based on the fact that the screen
on a force would well-placed something
like this is just netting black and
important porn queen g6 was maybe even
stronger than queen age four but it's um
it's clear that also queen edge for was
attempting news the next move bye-bye
Rashida graph really leads into huge
huge trouble if he now would have
canceled it on wouldn't have been that
bad in this tweet to Casper off he said
that he had of course considered queen
age four and after castles he then
suddenly recognized to move Knight to f6
which sets up this pin on the fourth
rank so white cannot take only five and
let's now face them with the prospect
that black wood shop is central point
forward and he said that he probably
very much overestimate
like this chances here which I do
understand I mean it's it's easy to see
that black will play efore possibly g5f
for this kind of aggressive moves and
it's not clear what White's counter
plays as the Queen side is closed
however if white plays a relatively
normal move here let's say poor not sure
Queen Queen back or queen queen here an
hour 22c to assess as we attack but
let's say let's move let's move this if
black decides to to close this here
White has this idea this is what I
wanted to show that gives him some
counter play and really black some
advanced here it's not that quick in the
making if he just pushes with g5 for
example white can also return if he
wants and then use the f porn as a
defense ya like like this and you're not
going to get mated here black is ok
definitely but it was probably very much
a overestimated by by Maxim machine
lagrave yeah he played the very
ugly-looking move g3 after which of
course screen geforce replied and now we
see that white already is in quite
substantial trouble the move Queen f3 is
very annoying and you basically never
can take the knight on e4 this night is
so strong and it cannot be expelled with
f3 if white would take blacker gets gets
an enormous position yeah with a huge
initiative yeah something like this now
with Bishop g4 in the making widest
terribly terribly placed here very very
difficult now to defend the computer
suggests the move Knight to g1 this is
actually a move that I was also thinking
of when I saw the the broadcast like
okay if it does not lose immediately
then maybe you need to play this to
cover you have to cover you
you weaker squares but tf4 is just just
very very strong I'm actually confusing
here confusing my notes it's not g1 a
movie later look everyone was played I'm
sorry Brooke f1 was played 90 580 energy
one this is the spot i'm sorry i was
looking at at the the wrong wrong move
here an igg1 this was where i was
looking at the position and thought okay
maybe you need to play this ugly move to
prevent 93 from coming but still with F
for like a retains a very dangerous
position you know something like this
takes cakes not this very very important
white takes a nap black can take this
intermediate pawn here in a way with
check yeah and here blackest is an
excellent shape we have equal material 6
points6 points but white has this
immense the ugly structure still this
would have been better than the game in
the game he went king to d2 and here
check like just simply collected this
pawn and went back it's just like okay
let's let's take the pawn and I have a
good position anyway what's a king is
running around and Dwight has no play at
all so sir just just excellent yeah he
tried and queen a5 and here you have
multiple ideas I think what kawana
played was very very good practical
choice you could have pre could have
played more complicated here but
community 7 is simply good the idea is
that if white intends to invade here
with the Queen you simply always have
this retreat available to to exchange
Queens and you're just the porn up with
the great position so a good move from
Queen g5 it takes and now we first went
to be seven looking at here here and
bound to capture later yeah so black has
a clearly better position NT has won the
H pond
so very nice yeah this is probably not
defensible anyway but after the next
move be three black will get really
directly immediately winning position if
you want you can treat this as a little
exercise black to play and and win okay
I'm going to tell you the move now it's
a v6 that's very strong it immediately
opens up the position on the White King
and has the point that why dia what
needs to capture what else is there then
there is c5 and this is very nice it
clears the way for the C porn and the
night now is really in a difficult spot
where should it go yeah he played a
night to be five what else is there and
then Bishop d7 was the point yeah black
is now covering the rook so he does
actually threatened to take on b6 and
maybe also take on a two later but also
in addition he threatening to play d4
which just wins the rook in the corner
and this is a bit too much why decided
to take their allowing chesty for more
yeah it does not look good but there was
nothing better takes and first you can
take here and then grab the rook yeah if
right now would recapture yeah he didn't
do that but if he recaptures there's at
least a simple Queenie for picking up
this rook in the corner so look take c5
check and Queenie form yeah black is
really just a hookup but yeah white
wasn't tired trouble and he just decided
to continue check trying to do something
with with his pawns but black could
simplify him and took on d4 here maybe a
group take seven was was even a a bit
simpler but it's black as a look up here
so we had some multiple ways to win it
took on deform c7 it continued for a
while
here funny move a five black can also
take the Queen ER but he decided to
first give back those checks and only
only then take the Queen after teammate
6 you can check capture here at here and
really that's it I mean b6 to be seven
just check check drops the rest of the
material so it really is true Taiwan is
70 and this event seven consecutive wins
which is probably a record it's it's
been discussed on Twitter and in various
forums so if there was a comparable
performance before like seven wins in a
row against this type of opposition
probably there wasn't there was of
course this is famous Bobby Fischer run
in the 1970s where he won in 1970 1971
and only 71 I think you won like more
than 20 games consecutively this was
where he won the last games of the
inter-zonal then he won 6-0 against him
on over 60 against bent Larsen which is
of course yeah and absolutely out of
this world result but it's not quite
comparable as it was reached oh it was
achieved over a course of month and here
we have seven wins in in a daze
sandwiches which is probably a record
ever see there was a cap off with six
out of six Indian arrows 1994 but this
is the only thing that really comes
comes close to this and we will have a
big game tonight um cara wanna playing
white against Carlton and I'm very very
curious about this game and very much
look forward to see what's going to
happen there Carson really with the win
as black could somehow repair this
tournament let's say
it getting at least an even score
against kawana and lifting himself to a
somewhat more bearable distance to Kara
wanna score I mean koala is leading by
three points he's got seven out of seven
on cards with four out of seven so a win
would somehow help to to heal some
wounds I guess but it's but black not
easy to do and yeah maybe maybe caruana
really has a chance to get to eight out
of eight if cards and it's doing it in
too risky fashion you never know what's
going to happen so in interesting a very
interesting matchup tonight yeah i'm
looking forward to that I hope you as
well and then definitely will cover this
round in my channel yeah let's let's
hope we get a good game thanks for
watching